ô coisa boa é comer eu gosto muito de
comer sério eu sou legítimo barriga nos
olhos aquele menino que botava a comida
do Prata a mãe ficava de olho em tu não
vai comer isso aí eu não vou eu tô com
fome ou índice não bota mais do que tu
guenta hein eu tô com fome eu vou comer
todinha botava o prato do tamanho da
Serra da Capivara e comendo chegava na
metade do prato eu já tava me sentindo
cheio e mãe aqui ó você vai comer
todinho eu vou comer sim meu eu tô com
fome e eu comendo aqui olhava pro lado
esperando mãe sair Cadê que mãe sair
bicho mãe fez eu comer esse negócio
todinho eu só quero tipo pessoa que você
tiver andando de carro eu estou a 200 km
da cidade não tem nenhuma tem um
vegetação não tem uma Alma Viva No lugar
se meu carro quebrar a primeira coisa
que eu penso pô se eu tivesse pelo menos
uma marmitazinha aqui no carro só para
comer um pouquinho